sein
aber
die schutzpatronin die macht irgendwo
importieren es wird ja nie nachdem es
bewusst aber ein sonntag würde das
deutsche bewusst dass du dann haben wir
da oben ist und sagt
schwerkraft
wenn er die oben einfach
loslassen tote am stein oder
cooper zu stecken irgendwann kommt da
unten an
doch schon groß geschrieben das ist auch
spielball
unser feld fällt dann musst du halt
echterhoff noch größer wieder klar vor
es ging wirklich nicht mehr so fekter es
wurde dann auch dort durchgesagt keine
chance sofort jeden rolle fällt aber
auch kein treffer und händen brauchen
oder sorgen müssen dass das wieder unter
dem gurt darf es den andreas warum nicht
einmal 33 jahre alt bist du geworden
das schicksal bars so wurde oft
gesprochen doch kann ich es bisher in
diesem verstehen dass du mein kleiner
bruder so zeitig musstest gehen auf
stehe ich nun an dem grab bin so traurig
und bin doch froh dass es dich gab
seinen geburtstag vorletzten münster
zusammen trinken eine tasse kaffee
kuchen und auf deutsch gesagt und meine
bitte nach zehn jahren noch nach wie vor
ich möchte noch nicht vergessen ich
möchte mich immer eine erinnerung und
viele sachen hat man aber auch schon
vergessen
adia den spitzen hammer entrich alles so
gelaufen ist wie eine ende das ist im
gang
und wenn dann doch endlich das sind zum
video sachen die man schon vergessen hat
das ist ein geschadet
ein
ich war jetzt 50 zum beispiel dann hat
dabei ich wüsste ich hätte wird in dj
oder grundfunktion da hätte ich ein
alleinunterhalter ich hätte inter gibt
mit bios und es ist nicht